we do get captivated by media by the
attention drawn to other countries to
the big animals that are that are being
slaughtered by poachers and we do forget
that we have the same problems going on
in our backyards
whenever we see a deer laying in a field
that's been killed in the middle of the
night with its antlers cut off it makes
you sick
but i think we forget how often it
happens here how often it happens around
us
in those times when there is a
conviction when the poacher is brought
to justice
i feel like we've all been able to speak
for
the ones that can't be heard for the
animals or the ones that have been taken
illegally because it's stealing from all
of us when a poacher kills an animal
they have stolen from every single one
of us
i keep doing this job because i believe
in it
because i believe it's the right thing
to do
because someday i want my children to be
able to say my mom did what she believed
in
she pushed hard
and she gave it everything she had
and i've had a good time
i love my job
you